les problèmes de santé mentale ça soigne
pas c'est à vie bah si ça soigne et puis
non un problème de santé mentale c'est
pas forcément à vie il y a plein de
types de problèmes de santé mentale il y
en a qui peuvent se régler rapidement
disparaître et puis ne plus jamais
revenir et puis oui il y a des maladies
dont on guérit jamais complètement mais
on peut empêcher que ça s'aggrave déjà
et puis on peut améliorer les choses
pour mieux vivre avec si on vous
annonçait demain que vous avez un
diabète ou une maladie cardiaque est-ce
que vous refuseriez de vous faire
soigner parce que de toute façon c'est à
vie non bon bah pour la santé mentale
c'est pareil quand il y a un problème ça
soigne et pour ça faut consulter point
barre les PSI c'est pour les fous alors
déjà un fou moi je sais pas ce que c'est
mais de toute façon vraiment c'est pas
compliqué les dentistes ça soignent les
dents les ophtalmau ça soignent les yeux
les psy ça soignent la tête il y a pas
plus de honte à se soigner quand on a un
problème de santé mentale que de se
soigner quand on a un problème physique
donc que ce soit des troubles anxieux
une baisse de moral ou un truc plus
sérieux quand ça va pas faut consulter
bar oui sergent instructeur